if I work with you I do not want to hear
from you online ever ever
Terry I know that we both sit next to
each other but it's a sign seating I
didn't choose that so when you come up
to me you say hey the barbeque looked
fun that's not the way you score an
invite I'm starting to get bummed out
Terry
Wanda stop asking me to play trivia
crack with you I don't play games on
Facebook neither should you mr. McCain
of course I saw your friend request but
if I accept that that's the equivalent
me just barging into your home it just
asked me to get fired and I can't do
that cuz I really need this job
like badly someone named Donovan I just
accepted your request I don't know who
you are I'm gonna assume based on our
mutual friends we work together
yippee chill Jen sup I really liked your
new profile picture
wait cube Jen yeah from reception damn
doesn't accept my request yet sexist ugh
the rest of you we see each other enough
as it is when I go home I just want to
see a curated life my friends are
pretending to live not your face again
Neil which is why we're starting the
hashtag don't talk to me if we have the
same signature at the bottom of our
checks if our only real life social
interaction is you asking if I saw Game
of Thrones if I choose not to see you on
a day that begins with the letter S
hashtag don't talk to me thank you
see you Monday